should see as far as I'm aware it's not  just me I don't think she's had a phone  call with the Welsh first Minister  either certainly she hadn't the last  time I spoke to him look it's just  really unusual um I've listed as the  fourth prime minister I've dealt with as  first Minister let's be honest We've Got  Deep political differences but David  Cameron was in office when I became  first minutes I think I spoke to him  within hours of becoming first Minister  and then when Theresa May and Boris  Johnson became prime minister certainly  within the first couple of days we had a  conversation so it's just unusual that  Liz trust hasn't decided to do the same  thing why that is the case the lack of  respect arrogance insecurity who knows  that's for her to answer